[Music]
[Applause]
Chris Haynes Bleacher Report NBA Insider
and sideline reporter for the NBA on TNT
he was there in Milwaukee last night
covering the 76ers and the bucks but
James Harden wasn't there Chris Haynes
joins us now why wasn't James Harden
there yeah it was weird it was really a
strange situation um he showed up on
Wednesday for practice you know he was
away from the team for 10 days it it was
an excused absence but they did not
think he was coming back at that time um
so they caught him by surprise uh and he
went into practice and A Team official
came up to him and said it would
probably be best if he stayed back um
and got help and got work at the
practice facility and James Harden as I
was told interpreted that as a
suggestion so he went through Practice
still with the mind of traveling to
Milwaukee for the season opener and so
after practice he goes to the airport
and then he stopped by a team security
official and told him he's not permitted
to get on the plane and so James is all
up in arms like what's going on here you
know and so general manager Elton BR
head coach Nick nurse they come over to
him this is at the airport and um they
explain to him how they need him to stay
back at the facility and so they can
track his progress his speed is
measurables because he's been away for
so long so James is still IR rate at
this point but he you know he calms down
and he he leaves without further
incident and U hard's Camp is of the
belief that they didn't want him around
for a potential distraction um having to
answer James Hardon related questions on
game day and um so he did show up at the
facility yesterday
to get his work in I was told uh but DP
I don't know what's going to happen from
here this is a situation that is I don't
think is not cooling off anytime soon
yeah but didn't he have a rigorous
offseason workout in Colorado and he had
people trainers there and a chef I mean
he was he was ready to go working out at
high
altitude you read my story DP yes I did
good good job DP yes he's in good shape
and that's why
um the NBA is getting involved too
because you know we have this new
star protocol where if a player is
injured so-called injured he still have
has to be at the game and be present um
visibly present for fans to see and um
the Sixers are this is so I'm just
telling you both sides here don't shoot
the messenger so the Sixers are like
well we don't know if he's injured
because he hasn't been around the team
for 10 days so we want to track his
measurables his speed to make sure his
body is right James is saying I'm good
I'm coming in in the best shape of my
life I'm good I came ready to be re
acclimated with my team so the NBA has
jumped in and they're investigating this
situation so I it'd be very interesting
to see what comes out of that as far as
the game what does Milwaukee look like
or how different are they with Dame in
there and not Drew h
the difference is um they have a closer
and Yannis told me in in our in our I
had a sit down interview with them at
air on TNT last night with Dame and
Giannis and Giannis told me it was
Dame's team and when he said that I I
don't know that I dismissed it but I
just took it as you know this is Giannis
trying to make Dame as comfortable as
possible um but if you saw in that
fourth
quarter Giannis was really deferring to
Dame yeah like Dame said it was at one
point where they were kind of trying to
figure out who's gonna bring the ball up
he said Giannis brought the ball up and
then he was trying to figure out if
should he come over and get the ball and
Giannis signal to him come get it come
get it and that's when Dame knew like
okay he wants me to you know he wants me
to you know do my Dame time and you know
14 points for Dame in that final F uh
five minutes of the uh the ball game and
the rest is history so um that's that is
what they get in Dame you know obviously
you know defensively Drew holiday is one
of the best um defenders in the league
and um he causes havoc on that end uh
but you know this is what they needed
you know especially you know we all know
Yan is one of the best in the league AR
be the best player in the league um but
teams specif excuse me the bucks you
know have problems you know during the
um closing of games you know Giannis is
not a a good free throw shooter and you
know teams tend to build a wall around
them so there there was problems down
the stress but with Dane they they got
somebody they can go to who's not afraid
of those moments and you know if he's
fouled he can hit free throws so it it
looks like a a really good partnership
between those two and it's really rare
Dame told me that um excuse me Giannis
told me that when they first had their
first meeting together after um Dame was
traded he told Dame I want you to come
in and be the closer and it's rare for a
player of that caliber to say hey I want
you to have the ball in the most
important at the most important time of
the game you know that that really just
shows how much Giannis really wants to
win he's Chris Haynes Bleacher Report
NBA Insider was working the sideline
last night for TNT the 76ers in the
Bucks we saw this with Dwayne Wade when
LeBron came to Miami LeBron has been
trying to at least publicly give the
Lakers to uh ad and so I'm not surprised
that Giannis is saying to Dame hey this
is your team but giannis's role now how
does that
change I don't think it Chang as much um
you know he's still going to be himself
you know he's still G to be his dominant
Force you know he I I don't think it
changes I think the only the only thing
that changes probably the last six
minutes of a game is
um I don't want to say deferring but he
knows that he has he know that he has
how should I say it he has a
um he he has a dog that he he can rely
on at that at that juncture in the game
um you know there's go definitely going
to be times I'm not gonna say Giannis is
not a closer or anything like that but
just know that you you got that escape
valve you know you know on the scene and
Damen L you know I just just allow a
little bit more freedom um for for
Giannis to roam and do his thing so I
don't think it changes much on his end
but just know you have the luxury of
having a guy like like that that's not
going to fold in those moments and not
just fold he's going to Blossom you know
that's that's a luxury that's a luxury
to have and so um you know but look
again DP you know Chris Middleton he
hasn't you know he hasn't um gotten to
uh play the the normal minutes that he
will play you know I spoke to him last
night he said he thinks he going to take
six seven Gams before you start seeing
his minutes become what they are um so
this team has a lot of room to grow but
definitely first game you saw how it's
going to play out Dame is going to be
that guy down the stretch best team in
California this year is
who oh golly oh that's a tough one oh
man that is a tough one I'mma have to go
with
I'mma have to go oh Lord Mike Brown's
gonna kill me over there you know I live
you know I live in Sacramento DP I gotta
I gotta deal with the Kings fans um I I
will have to
go I'll go with the I'll go with the
Lakers I'll go with the Lakers right now
I don't feel I don't feel confident
about that I go with the Lakers right
now the Warriors for sure you know um
removed from a championship
um Warriors and Lakers that's who I'm
kind of that's who I'm kind of going
back and forth DP what are your what are
your expectations for Wim bayama what
would be a good to Great rookie season
for him hey I was talking to somebody
about that the other day a good to Great
rookie season first of all I think he's
going to average damn near 20 points
probably more than 20 points uh probably
get you about seven boards a game but on
the defensive end I think that's where
he's going to be a killer from day one
um he might he might average three
blocks a game
playing 27 minutes a game something
along those line maybe even less I don't
know what pop has up his scheme as far
as his minute distribution for him year
one but I was telling somebody at worst
for Wim Bama's career at
worst he's a
multi-time defensive player of the year
guy at worst
now that is with him being healthy but
the skill set he has all the skill sets
to be something really special I think
again hoping hoping for good health for
everybody but for him I think it's a
runaway Rookie of the Year um I think
he's a runaway Rookie of the Year award
already just with the what he has
defensively scoring is going to come I I
I haven't seen anything like it DP I
remember NBA 2K is the game now that
that kids play yeah it's the big NBA
game but back in my day coming up it was
NBA live it was NBA live before it
became NBA 2K and I remember I can't I
don't remember it was the late 90s it
might have been late mid 90s NBA Live
started to allow you to create your own
player so I'm like yes I could finally
be in the NBA like I'm creating my own
player but you know when you create you
you don't really create you you create
the version of you that you want to be
and so the version of
me and I mentioned that you know light
lighting is always of course of course
of of course yeah dark dark brother
lighting yes absolutely it's me in these
hotels but I do I do it for you but uh I
would create myself and I would just
look so long and it would look so crazy
on the screen like having this seven4
guy dribbling and shooting threes and
that's what I see when I see Victor I
see myself I see the S4 version of NBA
Live and uh it's crazy to see we we've
always think we've seen a unicorn we
always call these players unicorn now
that is a
unicorn safe travel is always great to
catch up with you we'll talk to you soon
thank you Chris appreciate you DP take
care brother Chris haes bleacher
reporter NBA Insider and sideline
reporter NBA on TNT also has a podcast
it's uh called # thisis League uncut
Chris Haynes and Mark Stein wherever you
get your podcast take a break